[Música]
buenas tardes
bueno los voy a invitar a hacer una
experiencia diferente
los quiero hacer escuchar las tres
palabras más fantásticas que ustedes se
puedan haber imaginado
para eso les voy a pedir que se acomoden
bien en sus sillas
que cierren los ojos
y escuchen mi voz
listas
había una vez
ahora se los voy a volver a repetir
sigan con los ojos cerrados
pero ahora traten de pensar a quien
tienen al lado diciéndole estas palabras
en qué momento en qué lugares están en
qué tiempo traten de volver a hacer ese
niño o esa niña que una vez fueron e
imagínense a la persona que se los está
diciendo
había una vez
ahora sí abran los ojos
seguro que cada uno de ustedes viajó a
un lugar distinto en un tiempo
totalmente diferente al tiempo del que
estaba al lado totalmente diferentes
todos por eso digo que son tres las
palabras fantásticas y seguro que se
imaginaron a alguien muy sensible a sus
emociones
había una vez
tres palabras mágicas
una biblioteca
en san nicolás una biblioteca popular de
un barrio del barrio del carmen en esta
biblioteca
se dedicaban con mucho compromiso a su
comunidad a su barrio a acercar a los
chicos a la lectura aproximarnos al
libro
y había una vez un grupo de gente
inquieta y con muchas ganas de dar lo
mejor de sí y hacer por el otro que se
acercaron a esa biblioteca y entonces
nacieron los cuentacuentos nicoleños
y si en vez de quedarnos en la
biblioteca contando cuentos salimos y
nos vamos por la ciudad
y la biblioteca que muchas veces es
avanzada por las imágenes por internet
por los celulares por las tablets empezó
a llevar sus cuentos a distintos lugares
y trascendió a toda una comunidad y
mucho más
esos locos somos los cuentacuentos
nicoleños y llevamos cuentos
a las escuelas a los jardines de
infantes a las escuelas primarias a las
escuelas secundarias como dijeron recién
los presentadores a la unidad penal a la
escuela secundaria que hay en la unidad
penal ya hace tres años que contamos
cuentos allí a la sala de pediatría del
hospital
contamos también cuentos en las plazas
no solamente en las plazas del centro
contamos cuentos en las plazas más
olvidadas
contamos cuentos en tantos lados que
bueno hasta en los institutos de
formación docente allí estamos los
cuentacuentos
y aquí empieza otra historia había una
vez una cuentacuentos que un día decidió
dejar el libro con los cuentos que iba a
contar a un público que le estaba
esperando en alguna escuela y decidió ir
solamente con la voz
con el gesto y con el cuerpo contarlo y
todo cambió todo leerle un libro a un
chico oa un grande es algo mágico algo
único
pero contárselo solamente con la voz y
con la mirada y con el gesto y el cuerpo
es algo de lo que no hay vuelta
el cuento ese cuento que ustedes
seguramente se estuvieron imaginando
cuando cerraron los ojos el cuento está
en el ser humano desde sus orígenes
desde antes de la lengua escrita
el hombre contó cuentos quizás para
trascender con los que lo seguían quizás
para que supieran las historias que
había vivido y que no fueran en vano o
quizás solamente por maravillar los
contar un cuento es tan tan mágico
nosotros los cuentacuentos leemos el
cuento nos apropiamos del cuento y lo
hacemos crecer adentro en el alma el
cuento es nuestro y allí donde es su
destino ahí vamos y se lo contamos lo
que pasa en el otro es lo que
generalmente nos despierta sorpresas
porque nosotros realmente muchas veces
vamos con un cuento pensado a contar en
una escuela oa la unidad penal oa el
hospital pero lo que le pasa al otro
siempre tiene que ver con lo interior
con las vivencias que esa persona ha
tenido
ser cuentacuentos es un viaje de ida
digo yo no sé si está bien utilizada esa
frase pero tiene que ver con eso con
posibilitar al otro que a través de su
imaginación pueda crear algo totalmente
diferente
el narrador oral
había sido
sentenciado a muerte
dentro de las 24 horas y va a ser
ajusticiados
su delito
había sido contar cuentos
de justicia en un país de injusticias
esto había provocado una rebelión tan
grande tan encajable
que había que meterlo urgentemente a la
cárcel bueno eso fue cuestión de horas
luego lo capturaron lo metieron en la
cárcel juicio condena listo horas a
maduro
esta rebelión era tan incansable que
había que ahogar la
había había que decapitar la había qué
electrocutarla gasear la había
y desaparecerla borrarla
ese día los jueces y los asesores
tuvieron que ir a ofrecerle al narrador
oral que eligiera su último deseo era
una norma
entonces fueron hasta las celdas y le
ofrecieron que quería hacer antes de
morir y él pensó unos instantes y dijo
antes de morir deseo ir
a cielo abierto en la noche y narrar un
cuento
se miraron asombrados podía haber pedido
un banquete podía haber pedido hacer el
amor podía haber pedido una tumba con
nombre y apellido no la tumba la fosa
común donde iba a ir con los restos
bueno así que esa noche a las doce de la
noche
los soldados fueron hasta la celda y los
llevaron por ese pasillo ancho que tiene
la cárcel y al final tiene unas puertas
que dan al patio allí estaban jueces y
asesores y el narrador cuando salió
y vio la noche se quedó ahí en el medio
del patio observando ese cielo
estrellado
ahí nomás
como aire levantó la mano y la voz
y dijo el narrador oral ha sido
sentenciado a muerte y su última
voluntad ha sido contar un cuento en la
noche y en ese momento cuando salieron
sus palabras las palabras que se vuelven
mágicas en la boca de los narradores
una estrella fugaz bajo bajo bajo bajo
se puso ahí y extendió una alfombra de
luz alfombra prodigiosa y el narrador se
adelantó y subió y adelante de la mirada
expectante de todos
la estrella subió paso los muros de la
cárcel mientras el narrador se seguía
contando sus cuentos y todos los que
estaban presentes se dieron cuenta que
la imaginación es tan poderosa
que predice el futuro y a veces cuando
no puede predecirlo lo inventa
bueno les narre el narrador oral de
francisco garzón céspedes y les quiero
contar lo que sentimos nosotros y lo que
nos pasa con la gente esto de que no
sabemos qué le pasa al otro cuando
contamos el cuento no sé qué les pasó a
ustedes pero
una vez fui a la unidad penal a la
secundaria de la unidad penal y les
conté un cuento del hombre que había
tenido mucha mala suerte para él creía
que había tenido mala suerte entonces va
a pedirle al creador que por favor le dé
la suerte que le correspondía como todo
ser vivo
y va pasando por distintas situaciones
por un bosque por un desierto por una
pradera
y cuando vuelve con la respuesta del
creador se da cuenta bueno en realidad
él nunca se dio cuenta que había tenido
un montón de oportunidades
y entonces se acerca al finalizar el
cuento
uno de los reclusos y me dice señora
usted no lo tiene escrito
el cuento la verdad que yo lo copié de
escucharlo porque es un cuento de
narración de tradición oral
y le digo no pero te lo voy a pasar por
medio en la profesora y así te lo acerca
entonces si usted no sabe las
oportunidades que yo perdí en mi vida es
lo que le había pasado el protagonista
nada más que con un lobo con una chica y
con un árbol a ver qué imágenes le
pasaron a ese muchacho por la cabeza en
el momento que yo conté el cuento no lo
sé nadie lo va a saber pero le pasaron
imágenes que ni nos ni sabemos
en otra oportunidad
estaba contando un cuento en la
biblioteca la biblioteca popular a los
chicos de 10 años más o menos entonces
les decía que el hijo del elefante que
era un elefantito que tenía una trompa
corta así iba por el medio del bosque
entre los árboles verdes y los pajaritos
cantaban y los monitos pasaban de aquí
para allá y él andaba buscando el río
limpio porque tiene las aguas verdes y
grises para ver dónde estaba el
cocodrilo y preguntarle al cocodrilo que
comía y entonces una nena en la mitad
del cuento me paralicé ay para para
palabra me parece sueño que estoy viendo
una película
yo no tenía nada en la mano no tenía ni
el libro en la mano
por eso digo la imagen que cada uno se
crea dentro estar maravillosa
por algo es una es algo inherente al
hombre el contar cuentos y una última
una última experiencia que tuve fue una
charla de amigos en una mesa estábamos
contando un cuento yo les estaba
contando un cuento de un hombre que
había tenido una relación amorosa con
una amante que en realidad era su mujer
disfrazada entonces cuando la mujer se
hace ver le dice el mal
el marido les échos más sorbos pero si
está en casa como fannie su voz pero si
tu pelo hay querido para que existen las
pelucas a vos te gustan las morochas sí
pero los ojos verdes las lentes de
contacto morocha de ojos verde como te
gusta vos
hoy dice el marido pero tu piel tu piel
no era la misma
no le dijo es
no
mi piel siempre fue la misma eso no te
lo permite tus manos tus manos serán
otras cuando vos me acariciaban hay un
amigo de mi esposo me dijo pero mira qué
frase tus manos serán otras cuando la
verdad que yo no me dado cuenta esa
frase pero realmente digo que a cada uno
los cuentos lo hacen pasar por un lugar
que nosotros los cuentacuentos no lo
sabemos y en un mundo que estamos tan
plagados de imágenes que a diario
tenemos si llegan nuestros niños y
tienen nuestros jóvenes y tenemos los
adultos imágenes imágenes con la
inmediatez del
contar un cuento es algo único y que no
tenemos que dejar de repetir diariamente
porque la verdad que de esto del
contrario cuento no se vuelve lo que
ustedes imaginen nadie lo va a vivir
como ustedes
y ahora les voy a contar un cuento que
se llama la hormiga y es de marco denevi
un día la hormiga
las hormigas pueblos progresistas si los
hay descubrieron el alimento artificial
lo hacían ellas y una papilla fría con
gusto a hojalata pero la verdad que era
fantástico imagínense lo hacían adentro
del hormiguero entonces que hicieran las
hormigas dijeron esta es nuestra
solución pero aquí vamos a exponernos a
las nubes de pesticidas o a buscar los
pastitos o si llueve o si hace sol
cambiaron todas las entradas a los
hormigueros y se desarrollaron hacia
abajo entonces los hormigueros empezaron
a crecer y a crecer y las hormigas
también a crecer y a crecer y un
hormiguero se contactó con el otro y con
el otro y todo fue un gran hormiguero
comandados por una gran hormiga
bueno ahí empezaron a desarrollarse
generación tras generación la generación
llegaron a caer en el ilógico error de
pensar que el gran hormiguero era el
gran universo
un día una hormiguita empezó a caminar
por una de esas galerías que tenía el
hormiguero y de vaya a lo lejos una luz
camino rapidito rapidito y era una de
las puertas del hormiguero que se habían
derrumbado
entonces llegó hasta esa luz y se asomó
y vio el sol que encandilaba
pero curiosísima salió a ver qué haría
cuanto pasto verde de distintos tonos de
verdes de más brotes tallos
hojas y había una rosa amarilla esto
despertó los instintos básicos de la
hormiga y salió y se comió todo lo que
pudo pasto soja brotes yemas hasta la
flor amarilla
una vez que terminó de comer descanso al
sol si tomo un poquito de rocío bajó a
donde estaban sus amigas y fui me dijo
no sabía cómo decírselo
para tu hogar
amarillo
las hormigas la miraron
la creyeron local
y la mataron
nada más muchas gracias
[Aplausos]